what I'd like to discuss is the birth of
gene targeting and particularly our
contribution to this field first of all
what is gene targeting it's a method
essentially of being able to change any
gene in any conceivable manner in an
organism and our particular organism is
the mouse and so what we want to do the
mouse has many genes 30,000 genes and
this allows one to selectively
inactivate a particular gene and for
example if little finger disappears then
we know when the program for making a
little finger and and then that way be
able to deduce essentially what each
gene is doing by what outcome to the
mouse is when we are modify a particular
gene so how is this done these
experiments actually started back in the
1970s Richard Axel and wiggler had I had
shown a century if you make a
precipitate of DNA and put them on top
of cells the cells eat the DNA and then
a certain amount of it would then go
into the genome and be functional for
example if a cell is vomiting kinase -
this is an enzyme that's required - for
thermally update so if that gene isn't
there they can supply exogenously and
they added make it precipitate give it
to the cells and about one in a million
cells actually then acquires this gene
in functional forms and becomes
Dominique on a kinase positive so first
of all we thought well perhaps if we
actually made needles and very small
needles and they were like micro
injection needles like a hypodermic we
could actually direct the hybrid irmak
right into the nucleus of the cell and
thereby plant the DNA into the nucleus
and maybe that would work much more
efficient
and that turned out to work it worse
work instead of the efficiency being one
the billion is now one in three so one
in three sells acquired the sell in
functional form but the DNA went
randomly into the genome it didn't go
into a very specific place so we
repeated those experiments and what we
know that is if we put in multiple
copies of the same DNA what we found is
that again that all of that DNA went
randomly into the genome but something
very unexpected was seen DNA has a
direction you read it from say left to
right and so what we found is that all
the DNA molecules were lined up next to
each other in what we call Academy a
head to tail container they're all in
the same direction now randomly that's
impossible because we would put in a
thousand copies and a thousand copies
would all be head to tail head to tail
head to tail so there are only two
possibilities for how this could happen
one is that that one would act like a
template and then like a sausage machine
then turn out more and more copies and
they would all come out as one large
cantata mer again head to tail the other
is by a process called homologous
recombination where in essence two
molecules which have the same sequence
can amp be split and be put together
again and then again we would have a
head to tail kanima by homologous
recombination and we're able to prove
that indeed it was homologous
recombination now first of all that told
us that the cells had homologous
recombination second it told us there
was actually fairly efficient you had a
thousand molecules there all stitched
together by homologous recombination so
that was quite remarkable the other
thing that was remarkable is that we
were using fibroblasts
these are cells for example that are
present in our skin and that was unusual
because people previously know about
homologous recombination but they
thought it had to do with sex
it had to do with parents you know you
always get a chromosome from your mother
and chromosomes from your father and
then instead of getting a whole
chromosome yourself from one your father
or mother then they're split apart into
many many pieces and and stitched
together again by homologous
recombination so that you get a much
more variation essentially instead of
getting a whole chromosome you get a
chromosome that's made up of parts from
both your father and your mother
and in that way the variation of gene
copies of gene variation that you get
from your two parents is much greater
than if you got a whole block of
chromosome one chromosome from your
father and so on so it mix it up and so
that makes every sibling are different
from another and simply the combination
of genes that you're acquiring from your
father and your mother but we were
seeing it in skin cells in fibroblasts
which were derived from for example skin
and so that wasn't expected so so what
that told us is that the machinery is
there to do homologous recombination in
any cell of the body so that was the
beginning of gene targeting now we
wanted to go to the next step we not
only wanted simply to have a molecules
recombination between exogenous DNA
molecules but we wanted to be able to
have a molecule a combination we had
extreme a chosen gene that we're
introducing from the outside that we've
modified some way and then put into cell
would find essentially its Cognex are
the same sequence in the genome exchange
information with it and then any
modification that you creating the test
tube would now be present in the
chromosomes of the living cell so that
was the intent and we that was what we
wanted to do right away and also we
actually even wanted to do the mice
unfortunately it took about 10 years to
develop it so we knew what we wanted to
do we simply didn't know how to get
there and in retrospect what we're
taking advantage of is a machine that
normally are repairs DNA
example sunlight or oxygen radicals that
are produced by mana Condry or whatever
are destroying the DNA and they make for
example a double strand break so what
the cell first does is just jam to Deneb
it together again so that we're not
losing thousands of genes that are
distal for example to the centromere
which is required to segregate those
genes okay however at the junction where
those two a piece of DNA were stuck back
together again a gene is destroyed
however fortunately have two copies of
this gene one from your mother and one
fighting father if say your mother's
copy was destroyed then he can use the
information from your father's copy to
correct that and that's by homologous
recombination so that's at the machinery
we're taking advantage of and it's
impressive in every cell of the body so
what we had to do is figure out how this
machinery worked and then present our
DNA to the cell in such a way that it
would think it's the right copy and
thereby converted Sencha lee the copy
that's in the genome with the exogenous
copy that we're adding from the outside
that we've modified and that took about
ten years to figure out how to do it now
the other thing that was not a parent of
a parent right away was how to then go
from cells to mice and we knew a ref lee
how did what we wanted to do it
unfortunately the cells that we required
were embryonic stem cells from the mouse
and they didn't exist at that time and
then this is so now it were roughly in
nineteen in 1980s in 1984 we already
presented data to say well now we we
want to do gene [ __ ] what we do gene
targeting cells we submitted a grant to
the NIH the NIH found that project not
possible they said you know the
probability of century of your piece of
DNA ever being able to find that same
sequence in three billion base pairs
is impossible I mean the frequency would
be much too low and therefore it never
function and we realized that the
frequency was going to be low and so
what we were thinking about it simply
developing as a part of a selection an
example would be we have a defective
gene copy already in the genome and
we'll add a copy of that same gene with
a different defect either one by itself
would not be functional but together by
homologous recombination they could
respond in such a way that now they
would give you a functional copy because
there are different mutations on those
separate genes and so that allow and if
that gene is required to for the cell to
survive then you have a very strong
selection that may work I'll be able to
pick up events one in a million or so
and so that's the way we were
approaching it but still they were
skeptical they gave us money actually
for other projects and what we did was
to utilize that money to continue our
effort in gene targeting and fortunately
four years later we had information that
actually was working we sent to grant
back to the same granting agency and
they sent back a pink slip said we're
glad you didn't follow our advice so
that gives you an idea that you know if
you have confidence in a particular idea
go for it and and see whether you can
come through it's also risky in the
sense that if four years later we hadn't
had there any results we would have been
in deep trouble in the end a baby able
to obtain other grants simply because we
would utilize those funds for something
that didn't work
fortunately four years later we were
successful and the project continued the
other aspect there is you know how do
you go from cell culture to making mice
and for this at the time the most
attractive cells were called EC cells
and burano carcinoma cells and those are
it's our tumor essentially that's made
up of many multiple cell types
and but within them are stem cells stem
like cells in the sense that they could
contribute to the formation of multiple
different tissues and so I was going
from meeting to meeting looking at how
the progress was being made with EC
cells and it was sort of disappointing
in a sense that it was working to
contribute to tissues of the body what
we call somatic cells but it wasn't
contributing to the germline and there
and for us we wanted to go to the
germline because then if we ever made a
modification then we could then generate
as many mice as we want with that
modification simply by breeding but
those cells didn't exist and then
fortunately at around 1980 late in 1984
I heard rumors that Martin Evans in
Cambridge England had actually started
developing cells that may work and at
that time he called him ek cells and
those cells what he did was simply to
isolate rather than isolating these
cells from a tumor he isolated very
similar cells from an embryo and simply
used EC cells as the driving force to
say what kind of cells I want but now
instead of deriving it from the tumor he
was isolating them from the embryo
themselves and those cells looked like
they may be capable of contributing to
the germline and therefore would be a
suitable substrate for us to do gene
targeting with so I called up Martin
Evans and this was Christmas ad now 1985
and asked him if I could go to his lab
to learn how to work with his cells and
he was very generous and allowed us to
go my wife and I went there spent
several weeks learning how to work with
these cells how to use those cells that
action to make embryos in a sense of
introducing them to her what we call a
blastocyst the pre-implantation embryo
and then these are ek cells are now
called ES cells would then I'll
contribute to the formation of the
the embryo of the embryo proper once we
implanted into the mouse but fortunately
now these cells were contributing to the
germline so they were perfect for what
we wanted to do in in terms of modifying
mice so that essentially gave you the
background for us to be able to then not
only go from directing DNA at a
particular target in cell culture but
now extending it to formation of mice
with specific mutations
you